[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mercredi 1er décembre
voici les titres c'est la journée
mondiale de lutte contre le sida ce
matin des dépistages rapides ont été
menés à cette occasion à l'université
versailles saint quentin le nombre de
tests en france a largement reculé en
ces temps de crise sanitaire - 650
milles en un an nous recevrons également
et dia its vice président d'élus locaux
contre le sida
sa mission accompagner les personnes
âgées seules et démunies cela fait
trente ans que l'association des petits
frères des pauvres oeuvre sur le
territoire de plaisir les
clayes-sous-bois 35 bénévoles font vivre
cette antenne locale mobiliser auprès
d'une trentaine de bénéficiaires est
depuis un an certains élèves de l'école
élémentaire marcel pagnol de coignières
suivent un cours particulier tous les
jeudis ils s'entraînent aux échecs ces
séances se déroulent en présence d'un
spécialiste l'objectif améliorer les
compétences des enfants
tout à l'heure également la suite de
notre dossier de la rédaction consacrée
à la lutte contre les violences
conjugales focus ce soir sur l'étincelle
à montigny le bretonneux un accueil de
jour pour les femmes victimes de
violences l'une d'elles a accepté de
témoigner
[Musique]
à l'occasion de la journée mondiale de
lutte contre le sida chef prévention
santé et le crous de versailles organisé
une action de dépistage selon un sondage
ifop les jeunes en sable de moins en
moins sur le vih hf prévention alerte
sur les conséquences de ce manque
d'information les précisions de mathilde
franck en six ans que hf prévention
santé ne s'était pas rendu à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines pour réaliser des tests de
dépistage du vih en raison du coc vide
les campagnes ont été moins nombreux
selon le directeur ce dernier se montre
très inquiet effectivement on s'aperçoit
qu'avec la crise qu vides il y a une
vraie problématique sur le dépistage du
vih puisque pendant presque deux ans il
y a un retard de 43 % de dépistage du
vih ce qui a occasionné 14 % de
personnes séropositives qui n'ont pas pu
être diagnostiqués l'année dernière d'où
l'importance d'augmenter le nombre de
dépistages ces derniers sont gratuits et
anonymes et le résultat est connu en une
minute chrono je vais lui piquer le
petit bout du doigt avec le petit la
petite lan 7 je vais récupérer les
gouttes de sang dans la petite poire qui
va me permettre de pouvoir récolter le
sens pour pouvoir le mélange est dans le
produit numéro un qui est le dit blanc
donc il faut dire diluer le vent pour
que le sang puisse passer à l'intérieur
de la membrane ensuite le s'en passer je
vais prendre numéro 2 qui est le
développeur c'est lui qui va rechercher
justement les anticorps passe à travers
de 106000 200 nouveaux cas de vih sont
recensés chaque année dont 13 pour cent
des personnes sont âgées de moins de 25
ans sensibilisé les jeunes est donc
primordial puisque un quart des 15 24
ans pense que le sida peut s'attraper en
embrassant une personne séropositive
l'épidémie continue à faire des ravages
mais malgré tout rond il ya aussi pas
mal de gens qui ont l'impression que le
vih c'est pour les autres et notamment
les jeunes j'ai décidé de venir me faire
dépister pour pouvoir montrer un petit
peu à mes potes que c'était important de
le faire que c'était une bonne action et
que ça pouvait être que bénéfique pour
eux en france le virus du sida touche
plus de 170 mille personnes et avec mon
plateau eddie aït bonsoir en soit vous
êtes le maire de carrières sous poissy
conseiller régional d'île de france vous
êtes aussi l'un des vice-présidents de
l'association des élus locaux contre le
sida qui informe sensibilise les élus
mais pas qu'eux aussi les passions et le
grand public la crise sanitaire du kobe
de 19 a fait baisser drastiquement le
nombre de dépistages moins 650 mille
tests entre mars 2020 et avril 2021
d'après santé santé publique française
vous inquiète oui je crois que la baisse
la baisse inquiétante des dépistages
doit nous alerter elles doivent toutes
et tous nous alerter les acteurs et les
actrices de la lutte contre le sida car
le dépistage est vraiment la clé de
voûte de la lutte contre le sida et
j'aurais vraiment saluer l'action menée
par un chef prévention avec le crous car
ce sont de telles initiatives qui
doivent nous permettre de reprendre la
main sur la lutte contre le sida
aujourd'hui on voit la nécessité à se
remobiliser il y avait déjà avant la
qu'ovide beaucoup de mes connaissances
sur le sida cela s'est aggravé cette
pandémie de la corrida a tendance à
chasser une autre pandémique est celle
du site à une pandémie ne doit pas en
chasser une autre on doit vraiment
travaillé sur les deux aujourd'hui
pourquoi est primordial justement les
dépistages on sait qu environ 24 mille
personnes vivent en france sans savoir
leur séropositivité oui en effet pour
les cas diagnostiqués en ile-de-france
et 40% de ceux de la france pour 18% de
la population française donc on voit
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un besoin de mieux
informer mieux formés et si elle n'ose
ticket de manière plus régulière la
haute autorité de santé préconise
d'ailleurs une fois pour tous dans la
vie un diagnostic général et pour les
personnes ayant des relations avec des
personnes de même sexe tous les trois
mois environ avec des régularités aussi
pour des personnes plus à risque et donc
je pense qu'il ya vraiment un discours
grand public à tenir et c'est aussi le
rôle et la mission que s'est confiée du
locaux contre le sida l'autre donnée
inquiétante c'est le nombre de personnes
séropositives qui sont mis sous
traitement qui a également reculé -1 20%
fiancée automatique par rapport à la
dernière donnée qu'on donnait tout à
l'heure on sait aussi que les
traitements permettent aujourd'hui pour
les personnes séropositives est de vivre
avec une espérance une espérance de vie
justement plutôt similaire à la
population générale est ce que vous
craignez justement que moins de
personnes mises sous traitement ça
puisse influer sur la mortalité du sida
qui a fait depuis le début des années 80
à 38,5 millions de morts dans le monde
et ce qu'elle peut réaugmenter repartir
à la hausse oui bien sûr mais tout ça
nous montre bien tous ces chiffres et
aussi le fait de
commémorer cette journée mondiale de
lutte contre le sida qu'on a besoin de
faire des bilans de faire des points
d'étapes et de rappeler que cette
maladie est toujours aujourd'hui
présente que ça ne l'est pas que pour
les autres et on doit avoir une
attention particulière sur les jeunes
moi je suis particulièrement inquiet en
fait de la méconnaissance absolue par
nos jeunes des risques qu'ils peuvent
encourir une méconnaissance on l'a
compris qui a pu aussi et bien grandir
avec cette épidémie depuis 19 qui a
finalement entravés est les progrès de
ces derniers ces dernières années sur le
sida alors je disais d'être le vice
président d'élus locaux contre le sida
c'est une association qui a été créée en
1995 par jean luc romero qui est le
premier à lui avoir parlé publiquement
de sa séropositivité plus de 17000 élu
aujourd'hui ont signé le manifeste de
l'association votre mission
d'information de sensibilisation vous le
disiez tout à l'heure elle prend encore
plus son sens en ces temps où peut-être
qu'on parle moins du sida oui tout à
fait déjà salué l'action de jean luc
romero qui est un militant de la lutte
contre le sida pour qui j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration et qui a une force
et une détermination que j'ai rarement
vu ailleurs surtout pour un sujet dont
final personne veut véritablement parler
et donc oui
nous avons avec élus locaux contre le
sida une responsabilité particulière
qu'est celle de mieux sensibiliser les
élus les grands publics les élus ont
prouvé avec la crise de l'aco vide les
maires en particulier qu'on pouvait
investir le champ de la santé publique
c'est un échelon pertinent la
municipalité la collectivité
territoriale on a ouvert des
vaccinodromes on a distribué des masques
ont à mener des politiques de prévention
accompagner les ars tout cela peut être
fait aussi pour la lutte contre le sida
c'est la mission que s'est confiée élus
locaux contre le sida et qui regroupe
toutes ces collectivités engagées autour
d'un label qui s'appelle villes engagées
contre le sida et et jouer à carrière on
a illuminé l'hôtel de ville en rouge en
hommage aux victimes du sida on a monté
une exposition distribuer des quizz
distribuer des préservatifs sensibiliser
rappeler que cette maladie était
toujours là présente on est entre la
coded le téléthon qui s'annonce tout ça
est pas très évident pour les gens qui
vivent aujourd'hui dans un contexte un
petit peu anxiogène néanmoins nous
pouvons avoir de l'espoir dans la lutte
contre le sida si nous restons tout est
tous mobilisés car la lutte contre le
sida ne peut plus attendre mais une
épidémie en plus qui dure depuis plus de
40 ans désormais alors votre idée c'est
dire que le sida n'est dit ni de droite
ni de gauche mais se soigne aussi avec
la politique comment la politique
peut-elle justement aider dans cette
lutte mais parce que les mères ont
conscience qu'ils ont une responsabilité
particulière en matière de santé
publique l'état et centrale mais nous
pouvons aussi agir et cette association
allait taxer et c'est exceptionnel est
d'ailleurs assez inédite aujourd'hui
dans le paysage français des
associations d'élus parce qu'elle est
véritablement transpartisane et elle
rassemble vraiment des élus de droite de
gauche et du centre et des écologistes
et donc oui le sida se soigne aussi par
la politique parce que l'action publique
permet de trouver des solutions permet
de sensibiliser permet de transformer
quand un conseil communal d'action
sociale ccas
accompagnent
par des aides exceptionnelles des
personnes en précarité parce qu'ils sont
atteints du sida parce que nous
sensibilisons nos policiers municipaux à
la manière d'aborder les les malades
parce que nous mettons à disposition des
appartements relais tout ça contribue à
lutter durablement contre le sida il
nous reste un peu moins d'une minute si
vous avez un message à faire passer en
cette journée de lutte contre le sida la
lutte contre le sida ne veut pas
attendre soyons tout est tous mobilisés
le 1er décembre et tous les autres jours
de l'année merci et des revenus en
plateau je le rappelle maire de
carrières sous poissy conseiller
régional d'île de france et vous est
également l'un des vice-présidents de
l'association des élus locaux contre le
sida merci d'avoir été avec nouveau
[Musique]
dans l'actualité politique gérald
darmanin était ce mardi à sartrouville
lors d'une réunion publique sur le thème
de la sécurité le ministre de
l'intérieur a répondu aux questions et
directement posées par les citoyens
s'était allié à l'invitation de la
députée des yvelines michael braun
pivert retour sur la soirée avec céline
charles je voulais vous poser la
question que peut faire une liste de
l'intérieur pour que la sécurité
des français ils étaient plus de 150 à
venir poser leurs questions lors de la
vingt septième réunion publique de
sartrouville en présence de gérald
darmanin ministre de l'intérieur et de
la députée des yvelines il ya elles
broutent peavey sujet phare de départ la
sécurité
substantielle
c'est un des thèmes qui se dégage dans
la campagne électorale à venir même si
c'est pas le premier centre d'intérêt
des français même si c'est pas le seul
thème ça fait partie de ces thèmes etc
le cadre d'interventions du ministre de
l'intérieur délinquance chez les jeunes
drogue forces de l'ordre immigration ou
encore vaccination les thématiques
abordées étaient multiples répondre
directement aux questionnements et
inquiétudes des citoyens un format
participatif qui permet une proximité
entre élus et population locale je suis
élu municipal à montesson et que je
trouve que c'est fantastique d'organiser
des réunions où il ya de l'échangé de la
proximité donc je suis ravi d'avoir
d'avoir été là que j'ai appris des
choses et je fais ça très bien quand
vous faites de la politique vous
représenter les citoyens il vous donne
un mandat pour agir en leur nom et donc
la moindre des choses c'est de venir
régulièrement devant eux pour leur
parler et pour avoir cet échange très
intéressés et gym intéressés par notre
ministre à l'intérieur je voulais voir
ce qu'il en était au niveau du filet je
voulais voir si amis et s'ils allaient
avoir beaucoup de monde l'occasion pour
le ministre de revenir sur les mesures
phares du quinquennat d'emmanuel macro à
cinq mois de l'élection présidentielle
2h30 des changes des réunions qui
devrait se poursuivre encore dans le
futur avec de nouveaux invités
cela fait désormais trente ans que
l'association des petits frères des
pauvres oeuvre pour les personnes âgées
isolées à plaisir les clayes sous bois
mais aussi guyancourt et villepreux
créée en 1991 l'antenne locale compte
désormais 35 bénévoles qui accompagnent
une trentaine de personnes âgées
souffrant de solitude et de précarité le
reportage de céline charles et de
mickaël millero
30 ans d'accompagnement c'est ce que
fait cette année l'antenne locale les
petits frères des pauvres à l'occasion
bénévoles et personnes âgées se sont
réunis pour célébrer et donner un coup
d'oeil dans le rétroviseur de toutes ces
années au service de nos aînés en
situation d'isolement à l'époque comme
je vous disais tout à l'heure à l'époque
on a plane réseaux sociaux et bien il
faut des associations comme ça il faut
mettre 2 1 faut aller voir les gens
discutent avec eux essayer de régler
leurs problèmes il ya plus en plus de
gens qui sont seuls depuis sa création
l'association vise à soutenir les
personnes âgées à domicile ou en
institution en organisant des visites
des rencontres des sorties ou encore des
mini séjours l'émission ses doigts c'est
principalement de seconde à domicile
chez les personnes âgées donc qui habite
sol afin de l'horreur de leur donner un
petit peu de bon temps de discuter avec
elle et en plus de ça donc il ya des
actions collectives et deux bénévoles
envers ma danse ils viennent me voir
chaque semaine
ensuite on est les activités au local on
a évidemment les anniversaires avec
petits gâteaux et kd lang en france une
personne âgée sur quatre souffrent
d'isolement parmi celles-ci 300 ils sont
en état de mort sociale avec le
confinement qui a fragilisé les liens
l'association est plus que jamais
nécessaire
je pense que bon la crise sanitaire a
à fragiliser le
les personnes âgées elles sont encore
plus isolée qu'avant et garde a beaucoup
qui ont du mal à refaire surface à
revoir du monde à ressortir à socialiser
par six juges à nous permet de rire et
puis de voir bleus ne rompent la leur je
dis pas la solitude mais l'ennui comme
chaque année une fête de noël est prévu
avec un repas des animations et une
distribution de cadeaux le 23 décembre
prochain
là la suite à présent de notre dossier
de la rédaction depuis la semaine
dernière nous abordons la thématique des
femmes victimes de violence c'était la
journée internationale de lutte le 25
novembre dernier ce soir focus sur
l'étincelle cet accueil de jour
départementale est réservé aux femmes
victimes de violence les locaux se
situent à l'équinoxe le centre
d'hébergement et de réinsertion sociale
à montigny le bretonneux plus de 300
femmes sont passées par ce centre dont
chimène elle raconte son histoire au
micro de célia gars de son go ces
sourires traduit la fin d'un calvaire
chimène à 35 ans durant trois années son
mari l'a battu marié en 2014 au cameroun
avec cet homme qu'elle croyait être
l'homme de sa vie elle aura eu trois
enfants mais petit à petit le prince
charmant est devenu un monstre quelques
gifles et quelques coups est enceinte et
peut-être su j'aurais pu stopper ça au
début mais je me suis dit que c'était
une erreur et il a compris peut être
prêt après parce qu'après s'est excusé
qui le fera plus jamais bon j'ai compris
que peut-être ça lui a passé l'étape à
plus se mépriser et peut-être que ces
paiements aussi qui était la cause ce
sentiment de culpabilité exacerbée par
ses proches jusqu'à sa propre belle
famille chaque fois que tu es petit
commet des actes comme d'infidélité il
avait ainsi dell ou bien une violence on
me fait comprendre que ça fait parti de
deux foyers c'est ça qui fait en sorte
que si tu arrives à surmonter tout ça
c'est ça qui montrent que tu es capable
de gérer en couple n a reçu durant ces
années aucun soutien cachant ses actes
de violence à sa famille par peur d'être
jugé tu voulais rester parce que moi
c'était moi le moi c'était quelque chose
de sacré une fois que vous êtes mariés
vous devez tenir jusqu'au bout et
j'avais honte et peur qu'on dise que
j'ai échoué mali parce que c'est ça chez
nous lorsque vous dix ans et je n'ai pas
fait les enfants avec plusieurs hommes
moi je fallait tenir jusqu'au bout s'il
faut aller du plus à risque dont les
enfants elle vous ferai à chaque retour
de france où il vivait une partie de
l'année pendant cinq ans son mari
faisait subir une violence physique et
psychologique à chimène pour lui la
femme doivent faire le ménage et
s'occuper de ses enfants ce qu'elle
n'acceptait pas octobre 2019 suite à un
regroupement familial elle vient
finalement s'installer en france avec
son mari trois mois de cauchemar il
tapait sous - vous traînez communes
tirées par les pieds et mais j'étais
dans la chambre
alors qu'elle subit une nouvelle
grossesse non désirée elle trouve la
force de prendre la fuite en pleine nuit
réfugiée chez ses soeurs elle rencontre
finalement une assistante sociale elle
trouve refuge ici dans cet accueil de
jour départementale des yvelines pour
les femmes victimes de violences
franchement j'ai été
accompagné il faut dit parce que je suis
quand je suis arrivé ici j'étais sans
repères j'étais franchement acheter très
abattu j'ai d'abord eu beaucoup de
réconfort et vous accompagne aussi ou
avec
lamotte procédure depuis chimène a porté
plainte et enclencher une procédure de
divorce le jugement est en attente en
janvier prochain chimène devrait entrer
en formation pour devenir aide soignante
des centaines de femmes victimes de
violence comme chimène pousse la porte
de cette structure de travailleurs
sociaux spécialement formés les
accueillent nous avons la chance de
travailler en partenariat
cela signifie que la personne qui va
franchir notre porte va pouvoir trouver
au sein même de l'établissement par des
permanences une aide qu'elle soit
juridique ou bien psychologique ce
centre financé par l'état existe depuis
six ans et a permis à de nombreuses
femmes victimes de violence de les
accompagner vers une vie meilleure
la suite et fin de notre dossier demain
jeudi dans le journal avec le volet
juridique enfin depuis un an les élèves
de l'école élémentaire marcel pagnol
suivent des cours un peu particulier à
coignières des ateliers des chèques tous
les jeudis l'objectif c'est de
développer et de renforcer des
compétences transversales ces jeunes se
prépare pour le championnat académique
qui a lieu en mars prochain ses mythes
charges entraînées par le joueur et
animateur diplômé de la fédération
française des échecs claude chiron ses
élèves de cm2 ça donne une fois par
semaine un cours un peu originale des
parties d'échecs après une présentation
théorique sur un échiquier murale les
élèves se lancent en duo une initiative
qui semble plaire à ses enfants et
j'adore cgt pense que je les fais depuis
que je suis tout tout petit j'ai des
fonds grand-père j'adore mais quoiqu'en
je sais pas quoi faire parce que j'aime
pas trop perdre c'est très important de
faire ce genre de jeu surtout qu'ils ne
sont plus habitués à jouer
enfin moins habitués à jouer à des jeux
de société et surtout des jeux de
société de ce niveau qui sont vraiment
complexe un jeu qui possède de nombreux
bénéfices il invite les élèves à la
réflexion la stratégie ou encore la
mémorisation c'est un jeu des stratégies
et aussi ses des réflexions tu dois
réfléchir avant de jouer et du coup ça
t'aide aussi dans dans les devoirs ou à
l'école parce que trop on s'amuse
beaucoup avec notre famille bonjour
bonjour ensemble je me connais ça nous
aide à réfléchir nous concentrer quand
vous apprenez et ça c'est très important
que vous apprenez le jeu d'échecs en
milieu élémentaire lorsque vous arrivez
au collège eh bien vous avez beaucoup
plus de facilité donc à mémoriser et à
comprendre les choses certains élèves
sur trend victor peut selon ses
camarades faire un échec et mat en
quatre coups dit le coup du berger
espoirs de la classe il est souvent
sollicité par l'animateur pour enseigner
aux autres il a vraiment un accouchement
qui lui permet donc de prendre congé
entre élèves et je compte sur lui parce
que chaque garçon et mettre déjà dans
cette activité pour montreux groupe le
22 mars prochain les élèves raconteront
à domicile les champions de france
sortants lors du championnat scolaire
académique d'échec c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de votre fidélité dans un
instant vous avez rendez vous avec le
7-8 société mélanie poké parlera avec
ses invités du téléthon 2021 au
programme en fin de semaine et cette
année encore les commune yvelinoise sont
largement mobilisés ces belles soirées
avec tv 78
[Musique]